[Music]  keep your head down and blend in as much  as possible at least that's what my  family would tell me and then they named  me atsuko okatsuka  they went on to choose English names for  themselves  thanks Mom  or Linda  [Music]  my grandma raised me so I didn't really  hang out with people my age growing up  people were always like Oscar what's  wrong with you someone 50 years older  than me taught me how to socialize  whenever we would try to make friends as  a kid I was always like telling War  Stories  okay  trying to trade food recipes  [Applause]  my husband and I had an intruder come to  our house my Fearless husband he rushes  out starts to shake his hand in the air  like this the guy kind of watches this  freaks out and starts to run away  it works different fighting style  Mind Tricks  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]